Thanks so it is kind of a fun meta
experience does it just tilt some people
at the front here but like my dad lives
two blocks away from here
and I will say it's been a really meta
experience to wake up in your dad's
house with like it was kind of like I
was back in 16 when I was 16 but now
like there's a PI data in int over and
it's like I'm Velho and I can bike -
it's been fun we kind of want to talk
about is how to prevent miles of
scrolling and how to reduce the
spaghetti code from the copypasta
because I've been teaching Python for a
while I've been doing this data stuff
for a bit but I've always seen people
sort of like treat these notebooks as if
they're junk food and I figured I call
it untitled twelve that I PI and B but
let's be honest most companies you know
they they reach like 20 you know 42 or
some arbitrarily large number like we've
seen this untitled twelfth phenomenon
happen and and the thing is there's
actually kind of a way of sort of
approaching code that will sort of make
those problems go away because I think a
lot of people might have a way of
working it can definitely be improved
and I just want to show you like a
really quick hack to sort of show from
solve most problems after that I just
want to briefly point out the generality
of it it's not just pandas and notebooks
that we can fix with this attitude is
actually a whole bunch of things and
then I kind of want to maybe touch upon
how to learn how to get there but but
the first thing is like workflow really
matters and I remember this whole data
science thing started like in 2012 or
something I remember having to go to
companies to explain why we don't like
to use Excel for our analyses usually we
like to use other tools and there's a
couple of reasons for it so one of the
main reasons of not using Excel one of
the reasons why I think it sucks is we
want to separate the data from the
analysis one of the really really
painful bits of doing analysis with
Excel is that it's really hard to figure
out if that cell is like calculated or
if it's actually raw data you don't
necessarily have that in an overview and
that's sort of a source for errors
another thing that I didn't much like
about Excel is it was kind of hard to
automate the analysis so you have to
sort of get in your data sitting and
again you kind of have to do the manual
tweaking and you know that doesn't
really feel like you're a proper IT
person when you
do everything by hand all the time the
other thing I didn't really like about
it is that the analysis wasn't really
but producible if someone had an excel
file mainly because the data analysis
weren't sort of separated but it's
really hard to reproduce some Excel
analysis it's someone else made it's
really hard to add proper documentation
to it and this is kind of the last one
was kind of like a personal concern but
I think we should not pay a third-party
obscene amounts of money for something
as basic as arithmetic and I really
think the budget is better spent if you
allocated towards education of staff or
like an office party or whatever
innovation I really think that in 2019
we should not pay a third party to do
this and I also think that Excel is
still sort of around I think too many
analyses are still done with Excel and I
actually think it's kind of frightening
an insurance company depends on the
floating-point arithmetic of an expels
Excel spreadsheet and to make sure there
are pension plans are being Korea
calculated correctly and frankly I think
that's kind of frightening a lot of this
thankfully is changing now that we have
tools like panas and Jupiter so that's
good but if I'm being very honest if I
look at how most people use a notebook
and how they use pandas have we actually
solved all of those four points is every
notebook really separating the data like
the data from the analysis and is it's
super automatable and is our analysis
we're producible i mean i guess we've
solved part four but i think for a lot
of analyses we probably haven't really
consciously touched upon the first three
things so what I figured it might be fun
and I'll just show you how I think most
people start with a notebook and how
they do an analysis so I'll just do some
live coding here and hopefully after
five minutes with live coding
we'll have seen many things that have
gone wrong probably because I don't have
the right attitude of approaching a
notebook and so people say don't do live
coding during a talk and I'm just gonna
totally ignore that advice so here is a
jupiter lab instance and there's a
notebook called untitled 12 I imported
numpy I've imported pandas and I've
imported the matplotlib and I have this
data set that I'll be playing with
just want to show you a really cool
feature that you have a that you have
nowadays actually so what you can do you
can click this plus symbol in a new
version of Jupiter lab and besides the
terminal which is great to have in there
there's a new feature called a
contextual helper and a contextual
helper is badass what you can do is you
can just have contextual help here and
if your cursor is let's just run this to
do it and the idea being that this has
to run okay load a load if your cursor
is over a function from any sort of
package it has a doc string what the
contextual helper will do is it will
just sort of show you the documentation
on whatever thing your cursor is over so
no need to do the question mark in front
of the function name anymore as long as
you have the contextual helper there
that's your helper right there and I
would love to use it like in this case
but I can tap on the zoom in so I'm
gonna close it up but probably one of
the first things that people don't
really do much is just appreciate all
the features that you put her has maybe
taking a step back and just appreciating
some of these extra things that you can
use is also the thing that's gonna help
you a bit and especially the contextual
helper this thing is like badass it
totally changed the way I work anyway
analysis that's what I'm going to talk
about so this is one of my favorite
datasets it's from World of Warcraft
you've might have heard of this
videogame the idea is that you have a
character ID this character was a level
1 or rogue it's super serious analysis
and this level 1 or Krogh was apparently
in Orgrimmar which i think is the
capital of orc country and this person
was around at a certain time stamp and
we can see if the person was or was not
part of a guild and the guild is
basically a bunch of people that slay
dragons together but you're in the guild
or you're not and one thing I thought
was interesting about this data set is
the way it works is every time that
you're logged in there's sort of this
heartbeat in a system so every 10
minutes if you're still playing the game
there's gonna be another row of data so
that means that I can see how long a
person is playing the video game and I
can therefore calculate how long it
takes to get to level 60 alright so I
can sort of calculate how much human
time has been wasted on this video
so that feels like a fun analysis but so
in order to sort of play with that one
thing I probably want to do is I want to
sort of group by the character and then
what I kind of want to do is I want to
sort of well I don't want to assign this
but I want to aggregate this and one
thing I probably want to calculate is
just a number of rows and I'll just take
the level column and I can just say I
want the N peanuts size function to work
on that doesn't work level doesn't exist
hmm why is that let's look at the F I
think level does exist but the way panas
works is you can have a space in your
column name but no worry what I'll just
do is I'll just fix that so I'll just do
a C don't replace I'll replace the space
with I don't know nothing and then for C
in D F don't columns all just do
something like this okay this is super
clear to everyone great
and so what I'll now do is I'll put
brackets around this and I have the
number of rows we're just kind of cool
what I'll do next is I'll just cut like
the min level so that's the level and
I'll calculate the min of that and what
I'll do next is I'll calculate the
maximum level so that's level and then
max so that's also kind of good and I
think what I probably also want to have
is I want to have if you're part of a
guild I need to sort of summarize that
in some way and I kind of glanced over
it but as you can see in this data set
you can have like a minus 1 and your
guild which basically indicates you're
not in a guild so what's let's touch on
that so I'll just do your guild is I
don't know like your guilt thing and
I'll do NP don't max and then I and I
have a bunch of statistics here for the
characters and the whatnot so what I'll
just do this is a nice little
intermediate result so I'll just call
this D f2 and then I'll move on I think
we can see where this is going right
because I probably need some other data
set as well because what I kind of want
to do now maybe is that I sort of think
to myself like you know what I kind of
need if I if I want to do research and
what the effects of the guild is what I
probably need to have is I probably also
want to have you know how many people
are in the guild I think if you're in a
small
as opposed to like a big deal then
probably that might have an effect on
how you're leveling right so I don't
just want to have df2 I'm gonna have to
f3 as well and in that case what I just
got to do is I got a group by the guild
and then I just do this one aggregation
and I'll do something like I know a
number of characters is equal to I'm
counting yes I think what I gotta do
here is just do character and then
number of unique I think as a string
should do this and it's waiting a bit
but alright yeah and so the most people
are not in the guild but a bunch of
people are and then what I got to do is
I got to sort of I kind of want to join
this data set back up to that data set
so probably gonna do is like df3 don't
reset index and then what I got to do is
I got a called ef-2 that merge right so
what I have now is I sort of know the
guild number and I know how many people
are in that guild and this is sort of
now combined and I get to increase this
guy with another number which is grave
and at this point what you can sort of
do is you can sort of say oh you know
what I'll do is I'll just make a sort of
a plot out of this so one thing that I
can sort of do maybe is I think math
flip is on so I can do like a plot and I
can say scatter and I can say df4 and
then I can do something like you know
what I want to do is want to check the
number of rows and I kind of want to
check what the max level is then I
suppose that might be something that's
interesting to see right so the more
someone has been playing the higher that
max level is all right and I guess
that's kind of cool but I'm actually a
little bit more interested in sort of
the level increase I think right that
might be better so what I can do is I
could do DF 4 and I could do something
like max level and then minus DF 4 min
level something like that and what I can
do now is I can sort of you know even
though this operation is actually
supposed to go maybe in between here but
that's not how the world works because
I'm thinking out loud and then typing so
I'm going to keep this line here but now
can sort of say hey here there's a level
increase good nice now so time out here
bunch of stuff that will go wrong
suppose that I show this to someone I
mean for starters is probably the person
who has access to this notebook doesn't
have a folder called users Vincent's
downloads right so that already is this
kind of an issue and and what's more is
if I now were to share this with people
I'm creating the variable name under the
chart that needs it and that's not even
talking about all this df4 nonsense but
the thing is I'm kind of looking at all
of your faces I think a lot of people
recognize that this is sort of a flow
that everyone is using while making a
notebook and I get it right so if you're
doing this like you're sort of in the
zone and and hey I kind of understand
his dataset now some on fire so I want
to keep on doing the coding and stuff
but then that and I get that feeling
that you want to sort of really dig deep
and like dive into the rabbit hole but
maybe that's a dangerous thing to do
probably if I'm gonna do like a primary
analysis and then I have found a
conclusion that might be interesting
then I kind of want to be sure that I
clusion conclusion is at least correct
and I kind of want to make a system
that's very easy to iterate on that I
can actually share with my colleagues so
so so this way of coding it's not gonna
work cuz you're gonna end up having to
rewrite this and that's not effective
and you know I'm sure that we kind of
agree if I continue on this path I will
end up with a notebook where I can
scroll for them for miles and miles as
well all right which is also kind of a
painful thing so what I'm gonna do now
instead is kind of come up with it with
a better notebook I'm just gonna start
by saying how about I just call this
notebook what it is whoa
churn analysis or something just give
the notebook a name and I guess I'll
just go ahead and do is I'll just you
know take that code and I'll take this
code and sort of use this as a starting
point and now sort of think about stuff
that I could be doing okay so today this
has loaded and I mean one thing that I
could for example do like typically when
you
with a data set like this I mean if I
think about all the steps that are
happening here technically this is just
changing the columns thing but that
sounds like I'm cleaning the data right
and if I think about most analyses it's
probably usually kind of like always
this sort of phase where you're cleaning
your data set up so how about I just
give them a name
right so I'll just make a function
called clean data set and some data
frame will go in there and then I'll in
this case I'll just return that data
frame I mean that that that can be fine
and then you know one thing that I could
then do is I can also think of hey what
are some other things that I typically
want to do well that's probably a face
called remove outliers also probably a
phase that you're going to do and I
could kind of imagine that the way that
I remove outliers there might be
parameters for that and the function
kind of allows for that that's kind of
nice but then at least all the logic on
how to remove outliers is kind of
contained because if I look at this the
problem here is not so much that this
code doesn't work but it's that I don't
have an overview that Here I am
aggregating and here I'm adding features
so to say it might be nicer if I have a
function that says add features and that
way when I look back at it I know ah
anywhere where there's features being
added it should happen in that function
that makes it a lot easier to the bug
the only downside is if we're not kind
of there yet but like one thing that
might happen is that you do something
like remove outliers clean data set and
then you put your data frame in there
like this and this is kind of hard to
read right so the downside of this is
you can't have to read from the inside
all the way back out to the outside
luckily panas was looking at how the our
language deals with this and it kind of
made this cool trick so what you can do
these days is you can just say data
frame dealt pipe and then give that to
this function and in this case I'm going
to give it to the clean data set
function first and then to the remove
outliers
and the idea is that you take the data
frame it will then be given to the clean
data set function and it will then be
given to the remove outliers function
and there's a couple of things that I
really like about this for starters I
don't have to think about the logic of
my analysis whatsoever but I can already
write this down and this already gives
me kind of a framework of mind it gives
me a bit of calm and this is sort of a
great starting point for me to sort of
fill in the blanks and also as you can
probably imagine if I'm increasing and
increasing my analysis as long as I can
sort of figure out do I need to have a
new step here or does this action I want
to do can I put that in another step
that to my mind makes it much easier not
only to do the analysis not only to
iterate on the analysis but it also
makes it a lot easier to maintain there
is a trap though and I kind of miss it
it's a Python thing but I just kinda
want to show you but but I hope we kind
of like this idea it gives us more of an
overview like that feeling is good
that's very important but let's now I
let's suppose now I implement this clean
data set function right so what I can do
is I can say data F for the columns
equals and then I can do see dolt
replace for C in data F something like
this right and then what I could do just
to just to clarify I can check if the
columns that come out of this I mean
there's no space in there anymore so
it's a good thing the awkward thing
though is is that the same thing holds
for the original data frame and that
actually is a problem and we kind of saw
that happen here as well the issue kind
of is that if you're changing a data
frame as a step somewhere like you're
actively changing a property on top of a
data frame then everywhere that property
has changed so this action it would be
kind of nicer if the clean data set just
takes this data frame and it goes in
there and then a data frame that comes
out is updated without there being any
side-effects and in this particular case
a thing that I don't like and in general
it's a cause of errors is this one
function has side effects which is no
bueno
one really easy way to fix that is to
just make a function called start
pipeline and the only thing that this
function will do is it will return a
copy of the data frame and if I do this
I mean I will have to restart this of
course and now if I do this you see that
the we didn't change the column name to
the original date frame but we did
change everything in here and I can kind
of hear the troll in the audience sort
of go but ah Vincent that's super
inefficient like you know that's a screw
it I think at some point you can stare
set blind to this concept of efficient
efficient C but what I hope to show you
here is screw efficiency this is more
effective I really think it's okay it is
like waste like 10 seconds of compute
power maybe if that means it in the long
run I don't have to spend hours
maintaining it so as you're writing this
code maybe also the attitude here should
not be hey I'm focused on performance
maybe what I'm trying to do here is I'm
just trying to explain the recipe what
I'm doing here is I'm basically I'm
making a cookbook this is the recipe for
the analysis that I kind of want to do
and what I'm cooking a chicken don't
kill chickens because I'm vegetarian but
if I'm cooking a chicken I tend to care
more about flavor than the speed at
which the dish can go out to my family
right that's I think it's a better
attitude to have but there's a bonus
with this as well so I hope that we sort
of experience this sort of calm of mind
kind of thing but it's actually the
little bonus that we can do too so one
thing we could do is because all of
these things here are functions there's
actually an extra trick that we are able
to do so I will make a badly spelled
function here up here called log and I
think I've every heard of decorators
before right so yes you have so the idea
with a decorator is it is a function
that accepts a function and returns a
function it's really functional here's
how it works what you can do is you can
say hey I have this this wrapper that's
sort of on the inside and let's let's
just have a function we're going to
declare
function in here that will accept a data
frame as its first argument and then it
gets arguments and keyword arguments and
let's then also let's just do something
like import date/time as DT cuz gonna do
something with timing how long this
takes and one thing that I could do is I
could do something like okay we have a
tick moment that is the DT day time but
now and then we have a talk moment which
is a DT of day time dot now all I can do
is I can say hey there's a result which
is essentially this one function that
goes in and I'm giving it the data the
arguments and the keyword arguments and
I will return the results now but before
I do that I will actually print an F
string saying I can sort of say F dunder
name this is the name of the function
took and I can do something like talk -
tick and then every time I have a
function that accepts a data frame and
outputs a data frame then I sort of have
a nice little decorator here that might
be able to do some logging so what I can
do is I do wrap for a return wrapper
here a kind of cool thing now is I can
say hey let's add this decorator to all
of these functions right and let's not
also do this and let's like let's call
this clean D F so what comes out of here
if it didn't make a coding error it kind
of a nice thing that we get for free
here is that if we have a function here
that's kind of like nice in general then
we kind of get logging for free I don't
know about you but I like stuff that's
free because now I get to think hey
what's important for me to log here and
in particular one thing that I can
imagine for this you know a particular
use case I'll be removing outliers right
so one thing that's probably important
for this particular analysis is that I
keep track not just of the shape of the
data frame but also of the number of
characters that are still in here so
don't just care about the rows if at
some point I have an analysis and I only
have like 100 characters left not
another mine and a little power has sort
of decreased so one thing I could go
ahead and do is I can sort of do
something with this result and I can do
something like shape equals and I can do
like the results don't shape that's at
that
there as well the one thing I can kind
of do is I can sort of say okay it took
equals but I should probably also be
able to say mmm what's the nicest way of
doing this I guess I could do result dot
grouped by car AG and then I could do
something like and car equals no car
impede its size and I think if I get the
shape at this gap this is like the
characters sort of I think that's a
tough ball but right okay so don't I
should do and char of zero but I hope
you catch the drift I'm able to add
logging features that are important to
my analysis but here's the epic thing
now suppose as luck might have it that
this analysis is something will actually
go to production notice that we've just
fixed logging and also just an extra
bonus suppose now at some point that
these functions are well written and
well defined what I could even do this
is amazing feature of Python you can
make a file you can call it common the
PI you could put that stuff in here and
that it could import it and that's
important and the reason for that is is
that means that we can now use the
notebook as a scratch pad but the moment
that the function is sort of mature
enough that we can remove it from the
notebook such at the notebook then
becomes the summary it becomes a user
interface it becomes a place where we
can sort of very quickly make nice
little charts instead of it having to be
like the repo of all of our sort of
analytical steps and of course the next
step would be the sort of if not just
have this into common that PI but to put
this into a package right that's will be
a nice little next step you can automate
that with a cookie cutter I've
open-source mine but then also a very
very awesome thing is this is a function
you can unit test that so not only do we
sort of have this nice little way of
sort of separating the macro part of our
analysis with a micro part of our
analysis but we have a very nice way of
unit testing this so I
sleep better at night and I don't know
about you but I like having paid your
duty off on a Sunday but also I'm just
happier because I think it's going to be
a whole lot easier for me to sort of
change the analysis if I'm able to sort
of make quick changes on this level
because a very convenient thing is what
I could do is I could say something like
hey I've been I've a minimum number of
rows that I have Pro character and as
long as this keyword argument I have
here also exists here you know then you
can you can fiddle around on a high
level and keep the details on a low
level and therefore separates into two
different levels of abstraction which is
the whole goal of programming I'll take
questions after you would add oh you
could I guess but then you're copying a
lot right and your copy you're copying
on every single function out there
there's another reason to have to start
pipeline in here notice that suppose
that this clean data set removed a
couple of columns by having start pipe
line in here I have this one log line
that tells me how big was the data frame
before we got started I think that for
me that's the main reason of having a
start pipe line the copying thing is
nice it's a cool security mechanism but
I like having that one log line because
if it didn't have that start pipe line
function the second line of the logs
will not show me the original size so
it's a good is a cool idea but I kind of
prefer this so I can imagine and this is
something I've learned about teaching
understanding a decorator and
understanding a lot of these steps it
kind of takes a bit of maturity if as
far as being a Python 4 developer goes I
do genuinely think that if you're just
getting started and you're reading the
panas documentation you're not going to
hit this great habit probably because
you know a decorator is a relatively
advanced thing you can do in Python it's
not just a common scripting so it might
be nice if just you know there's some
easy tools here that might help you with
this so there's a package I've made
together with a bunch of lovely people
it's called psychic Lego it's a really
cool because we have stickers
somewhere but one thing we've added and
this sort of the idea like I've noticed
that for panda isn't for scikit-learn
there's it's not so much that the
pipeline isn't there but it's more that
sometimes you need like a little Lego
brick that you can just click in there
for your particular type of analysis so
if you're interested we actually not
only have the log step as a feature but
we also have a tutorial on how to get it
to work with the Python logging
framework so what you can actually do
with this log step that we have here is
you can actually sort of say hey not
only do I want to log this step but also
I want to set the logging level for this
function to be different than the
logging level for this function such
that in production I'm logging other
stuff than stuff that I have in my
notebook so if I look at where we then
are I mean I think if you write the like
if you do the piping thing you will
actually just sort of for free are a lot
closer to solving the first three
problems literally you've also solved
the fourth one because it's for free but
that but but the thing is like I sort of
noticed that if you're doing data
science and stuff don't worry too much
about the algorithm don't worry too much
about the deep learning stuff like
google has obscene amounts of compute
that you don't have so what they are
doing might not work for you different
signal okay whatever but what I hope
though is that what I've just shown you
is that if you're interested in reading
more about this everything I've just
talked about I got that from a blog from
the one of the panels Cortez it's not
something I came up with but I kind of
want to hope that this feeling of just
clicking stuff together just note the
beauty and the generality of this I mean
you can teach you this approach to the
team and then everyone can still write
their own functions their own way but at
least there is this shared principle
echo approach to code that everyone got
warm can adhere to and just that is
going to make it a whole lot easier for
you to communicate what you're doing to
your colleagues if we all just promise
that we have a clean data set phase and
a remove outlier phase
and that everything else is sort of very
particular to the to the analysis that
we're doing the only thing you got to do
is call with a good function name that
describes what you're doing and you can
you can actually actively focus on that
and if actually like I've had code
reviews where we spent ten minutes
coming up with the best name for a
function and I think there's value with
that so pipelines need Lego bricks and
I've been fortunate enough to sort of
have this experiment become a bit
successful we have about 2,000 thousand
downloads a month now we are even like
it's weird if I push to pi PI I
immediately notice the CDN providers
picking it up so after I've made a new
version within five minutes I have 300
downloads from like all the CND CDN so
it's like a huge compliment there's a
couple of Dutch companies helping us out
with this and the guy from Brazil if
you're interested in this like fineness
and github we kind of we have lots of
fairness algorithms as well if you're
interested in that but we kind of see
this as a very cool experiment to just
come up with hey what are some good
industry practices that don't
necessarily fit well if I could learn or
in pandas but is stuff that you know I
would I would maintain it because it's
tough I want to use every day and I'm
not the only one doing it Mattias is
around there the sort is it but we are
the two main maintain errs but there's a
bunch of other people come and enjoy the
fun also just to emphasize this is why
scikit-learn is amazing right so I could
learn gives you this pipeline which sort
of automates all a lot of cognitive load
away from you and the pipeline is a bit
different because this pipeline actually
requires state so that means that the
Lego bricks in this particular case are
not functions they're objects but the
whole point is that you have a pipeline
and that's the thing that's making sure
everything runs fine for me personally
this is why space is such a badass
project NLP algorithms are great but
only when they click together and for me
at least the problem that space has to
solve is just making sure we have a
convenient API or a convenient pipeline
abstraction to do NLP stuff which means
that you can bring your own Lego bricks
which is the beauty of it also it has an
amazing community like Joyner the space
he's amazing but I hope that I've kind
of demonstrated something general to all
this too because there's a great cooking
analogy if how I think most people cook
is they take the chicken
season it with spices then they season
it with gravy and then they put it in
the oven at a certain degrees of Celsius
and then they serve it on a plate what
they don't do is serve the thing that
you put in the oven which is the thing
that you season which is the thing that
code is language you don't there's no
human being who would consider talking
like this and there's also no human
being who would consider talking like
this right but if we are to maintain
something then I prefer to have
something that you can just read from
but from left to right top to bottom and
a pipeline is a really nice way to make
sure you always stick to that a pipeline
is literally this than that than that
than that so considering that code is
more like a user interface for thoughts
and it's really important to get it
right because I think if you invite
clarity and interoperability you're
gonna get a much better sort of
experience in your career it also is
what I think makes our a really nice
language so just some advice I guess I
mean maybe really don't worry about
learning the latest deep learning
technique instead invest more about
having stable code typically more of a
productive concern to worry about hey
how can I communicate clearly with my
colleagues then how can I use this super
complicated model I've never seen that
idea work but I'd love to hear someone
say oh I tried something super complex
once and the team immediately got it to
work and it was great green fields and
rainbows it's just that what I have
heard though is hear stories of hey we
actually took two months to sort of to
really talk about how should we
communicate with each other and now we
live in a more calm environment clarity
will typically cause many improvements
in the long run and the calm that will
follow is likely going to have a greater
impact in innovation compared to yet
another library that can flow a bunch of
tensors typically panas is a tool that
you will use daily so it feels really
weird to me that people don't make sure
they 100% master it if it's something
you use daily then it's something that
you really want to sort of get to the
bottom of and I do think probably more
time is spent in pandas in this I could
learn if I'm honest and it's a bit meta
but and your experience might certainly
be different but I have found it to be
really effective to have this calm
because if you have this sort of calm
hey nothing is on fire kind of vibe gone
then that means that you can pause and
kind of reflect on how everything's
going and without this pause you cannot
really find a thing that you can improve
it doesn't give you an opportunity to
rephrase what's happening so don't go
down the rabbit hole of untitled 12
it's like haste makes waste and it's
kind of meta but if I really just think
about it I like to make drawings when I
think about stuff but I really think
that you have to reflect in the calm
moment that you are in and then you're
able to make a good investment in your
habits and the joy will just accumulate
it's it's something that will sort of
get better over time but the problem is
that most people think oh I should focus
on the habits I think you just start to
focus on the reflection just take a
moment every week look at everything
you've done and wonder is there
something that we might be able to do
better and with that I mean stuff that
I've been doing lately I kind of noticed
I have lots of these itches to scratch
but then nowadays I just don't wait for
someone else to build it I just fix it
myself so I've noticed for teaching I've
always had this weird use case that I
just want to draw a dataset and then
just use it so there's this you know
thing I made it's called draw data about
X Y Z and what you're able to do is you
can just draw a bunch of points and you
can click a button that says copy CSV
copy Jason Davao Jason download CSV and
there's a reset button it's a free tool
go ahead and use it but scratch your own
itch but before you scratch your own
itch reflect if this is something that
you want and typically it's a lot easier
to solve the right problem if you
understand the problem very well the
future is awesome I think the only thing
we got to do is just build it almost
exactly kind of kind of bummed out for
that thankful
you